um is it good
that many of the most powerful federal
elected officials in the united states
are in their 80s
or even close to their 90s in some cases
now let me set this up for you
last week republican senator chuck
grassley announced he's going to be
running for re-election uh he is 88
um senate terms are six years long we're
talking 90s if he wins
joe biden is almost 79. nancy pelosi
speaker of the house is 81. steny hoyer
is 82. jim clyburn is 81. those are the
top three democrats in the house of
representatives over in the senate the
democratic leader chuck schumer is only
70. republican leader mitch mcconnell 79
years old senator dianne feinstein 88
years old bernie is 80 years old patrick
leahy is 81.
jim inhuff is 86. i can give you the
list fine
this is not about ageism
uh republicans have actually been using
aegis tropes against joe biden joe
biden's barely older than donald trump
their big alpha boy strong hero
joe biden's barely older republicans
have been using a lot of aegis
tropes against joe biden i have no
interest in like just a generally aegis
discussion it's more about
is this country well represented
if our elected officials skew
so dramatically older than the average
population now to some degree it makes
sense
five-year-olds contribute to the average
population but five-year-olds can't be
senators so like to some degree it would
make sense that our elected officials
are older than the average population
but we're talking about dramatically so
we've also talked before about whether
there should be an upper age limit for
president for example this isn't about
you know imposing anything some people
want an upper age limit this is more
about whether it could be argued that
the population of the united states
overall
is well served
and well represented by folks who skew
dramatically older there's a strong case
to be made that the answer is no now at
the same time we want people who are
more experienced
oftentimes people get good at their jobs
after they've been in the job for a
while you can also have corruption and
rot which sets in when people have been
in their jobs for a while
we want people who know how these
legislative bodies work and know how to
get things done and if you increase
turnover dramatically in the house and
senate you probably increase this
revolving door of lobbyists and a number
of other problems now aside from an age
limit
you can also look at term limits but
there's quite a bit of literature in
terms of term limits which says
term limits create corruption
and they create incompetence because you
force out lots of people
who could be doing their job really well
they force people out as they become
more experienced and you create the
opportunity for moneyed interests to
interfere and swoop in
right legislation it's a complicated
issue for sure
the idea of an age limit is not unheard
of many people don't know
that canada has a maximum age for
senators there's mandatory retirement
for canadian senators at age 75.
um so then we get at the end to
turnout is really low in the united
states without changing anything about
the rules term limits maximum age or any
of this stuff
if more people wanted younger elected
officials
they could get out and vote for them
support them in primaries and the
problem would sort of take care of
itself now many people would say hey
there's too many 80 year olds and my
generation's not represented and i'm
going to go out and vote but a lot of
the people who say that don't actually
go out and vote does that make sense no
but it's the situation that we have so
do we really need age limits do we
really need term limits or do we just
need more voter participation and higher
turnout from younger people who are
overwhelmingly underrepresented in the
electorate that chooses to vote
it would make sense like if you step
back from all of this if older folks are
more reliable voters
it makes sense
that you might see older folks also over
represented in terms of who wins so let
me know your thoughts is this question
one is is this really an issue that
elected representatives particularly in
the senate and in general in federal
government skew older
and if it is a problem
are we better off leaning on a solution
like a term limit or an age limit or
this is this really just an issue of
apathy among those who casually would
like younger representatives but aren't
actually going out and voting in
significant numbers let me know your
thoughts is it a problem and what is the
solution if so you can find me on
twitter at dpakman